-Hi.
-How are you?
-I´m good. I´m cheating.
I´m bringing something --
I didn´t tell you about it.
But it´s like
a show-and-tell moment.
-Oh, what is it?
-Todd Oldham went to
a flea market in Texas
and he found these
flyswatters that somebody --
What you do is --
you take a flyswatter
and then you just use embroidery
thread and you decorate it.
And then it´s good, like, for
a sneeze guard, maybe,
or you´re talking to somebody
who´s close or masquerade.
-That´s great.
But then you don´t use it
as a flyswatter anymore.
-No. You ruin it.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Anyway, it´s
a good idea, right?
-That´s a wonderful idea.
-The holidays are approaching,
and it´s inexpensive to make.
-That´s great.
Now, the reason I asked if you
would use it on an insect is --
I know you had some moth issues
last time you were here.
-[ Laughs ]
That´s right.
-And you do taxidermy
and you had
this taxidermy chipmunk.
And the moths had been
very unkind to it.
-Yes.
And it all happened overnight.
-That happened in one night.
-They must have
been planning it,
´cause I looked up and
I was like --
Yeah, but his name was Waffles.
-Uh-huh.
-I saved the crown.
Isn´t that terrible?
-That is terrible.
-And then they ate my squirrel.
-They ate a squirrel, as well?
-Yeah. Two things.
-And, now, have you made any
progress in stopping the moths?
-I found the nest.
-You did?
-It was in my bedroom.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Are nests, like,
up in the corner?
-It was under the carpet.
I shouldn´t even say --
I took mushrooms one night.
I was with my friend.
I was like, "I think
I know where the nest is."
We found it under the carpet.
I took an X-Acto blade
and I was cutting the carpet up.
And he´s like, "Wait a minute.
We shouldn´t be
doing this on mushrooms."
So I put the knife away,
we went outside,
and then I took care of
it the next day.
So I don´t have
a moth problem anymore.
-Oh, that´s great.
But you do have
a rug problem, it sounds like.
-Oh, yeah.
-Not just from you,
because we also
talked about your rabbit, Tina.
-Tina.
-And she was
chewing up furniture
last time you were here.
-She chews everything, man.
-Is she still at it?
-Yeah, she´s still at it.
She digs and she burrows.
And, yeah, so, I bought
a new rug, and it was expensive.
And I have a friend
who got me a deal on it.
And then I picked up my mattress
to vacuum underneath it,
and this is what I find.
-So, she had just eaten --
That is --
It seems crazy that,
with your moth problem,
you would bring
another eater into the home.
-Can you believe that?
She even went through the pad.
-Wow.
-But I highly recommend
them as a pet.
They really are great pets.
-They really are.
You really like your rabbit pet.
-Yeah. They´re quiet.
-Uh-huh.
-I like that
they´re prey animals
and that they can kick back
and relax in your home.
I like having that power.
-Oh, that´s nice.
-Yeah.
-I never heard of rabbits
are great so you can have power.
-Well, I mean,
you know, normally,
they always think
they´re gonna be eating,
so they´re all stressed out.
-Uh-huh.
-But she´s not.
She´s kicked back and relaxed --
when she´s not
chewing and clawing.
-You play --
So, your show is about --
Like, you play a homemaker,
but you play a
bunch of different characters.
-I do.
-I have some photos,
and I would love you to just
give me a little background on
some of the characters you play.
-All right.
-All right, so,
give us a little bit about --
-[ Southern accent ]
That´s Patty Hogg.
She´s the heir to the
Coral and Hogg Seed Company.
And she´s shorter
than me, somehow.
-Oh, wow.
That requires an
incredible amount of acting
to do different heights.
-Yes. I mean,
yeah, isn´t that great?
And I wear a fake belly.
-Oh, you wear a fake belly.
This is -- So, the nose
I have questions about.
-I´ve been doing that
since I was 3.
You know, when you
take your nose up.
I still do it and
I have perfect skin for that.
-Oh, great.
-You have to have
good skin to do that.
-And do you have
skin that´s adhesive?
-I don´t know.
It´s something about my skin.
And I can keep it
up there for hours.
And it feels good.
It gives it a bounce.
-Who do we got here?
-Oh, that´s
the international wine lady,
regional wine lady.
And she sings this song.
♫ It´s Friday night ♫
♫ I´m gonna get drunk ♫
♫ I´m gonna get laid ♫
♫ I´m gonna be late on Monday ♫
♫ Oh, hello ♫
And I have
the little alcoholic nose.
-Okay. And then
this one seems very committed.
-Yeah, he´s my hobo.
-Okay.
Everybody has to have a hobo.
-Yeah, he´s a hobo.
He does things on the sly.
You know, he´s great.
But I do his voice -- He sounds
like my little brother.
[ Southern accent ]
He kind of talks up, like, this.
Hi, Seth. How you doing?
-So, your little brother
always talks up like that.
-He kinds of talks like that.
He gets accused of being a
woman on the phone all the time.
-Oh, that´s --
-Yeah.
"Yes, ma´am."
He just laughs.
But Sarah Egan did all the
makeup for those characters,
and now she works on this show.
-Yeah. She´s wonderful.
And I remember
when she started here,
she talked about what a
delight it was to work with you.
-She´s the best.
-She´s great.
-Now we need to negotiate,
because if we get picked up,
I want her back.
-Yeah, you can --
I will say, like,
this seems to be
a far more interesting job
to do makeup on
than do this every day.
-You don´t even
have any makeup on.
-Like, I haven´t done hobo
once since this show started.